Hi mystery recapped here . Today
I'm going to explain the second part
of the action sci-fi movie Parasytes.
Spoilers ahead. Watch out and take care.
The movie begins with the police using a serial
killer named Uragami to identify mysterious
aliens that have invaded the humans.
These aliens are called the parasites and
infect the humans by entering their brains.
These parasites take over the human consciousness
and turn them into violent cannibals. The police
are hopeful about identifying the aliens through
Uragami, who has witnessed the parasites feeding
on humans before. They bring Shinichi before the
serial killer but he fails to identify him.
After being let go, Shinichi continues to hunt
down the parasites who terrorize the humans for
food with the help of Migi, the parasite that
affects his right hand. Although Shinichi is
still a human, he is progressively growing
stronger because of Migi. Using his powers,
he effortlessly takes down a parasite feeding on a
human in an abandoned building. After killing the
alien, Shinichi feels someone’s presence
outside and rushes to inspect. However,
he fails to notice an investigative journalist
named Shiro Kuramori hiding behind a pile of
junk. Kuramori has been secretly spying
on Shinichi and Migi for a while now.
The city’s mayor Takeshi Hirokawa, who has also
been taken over by the parasites, grows worried
about Shinichi killing the aliens. He complains
about Shinichi to Ryoko Tamiya, the leader of the
parasites but she forbids him from going after the
boy. Tamiya, who now is a mother to a human baby,
intends to use Shinichi and Migi for her research
on the parasite’s coexistence with the humans.
Afterwards, Hirokawa meets with another parasite
named Goto. Goto is an extremely powerful parasite
as his body is made up of 5 parasites.
Goto advises Hirokawa to kill Shinichi.
It is then revealed that Kuramori was hired
by Tamiya to spy on Shinichi. He hands her the
evidence he has collected so far and suggests
they should give it to the police. However,
Tamiya advises him against it, saying they need
more information on the boy. Kuramori, who is
a single father of a girl named Yumi, has grown
close to Tamiya over time. He relates to Tamiya,
who is also a single parent and agrees to continue
to gather more information on Shinichi.
Shinichi eventually catches Kuramori
following him red handed with a camera
and confronts him. Migi asks Shinichi to kill
the reporter but he refuses to kill a human.
After learning that Tamiya had hired him to spy
on them, Migi tells the reporter that she is a
parasite herself and much more dangerous than
other parasites. Shinichi and Migi tell Kuramori
that he is playing with fire and advise him to
stay away from Tamiya and keep a low profile.
Kuramori is in utter disbelief but
decides to continue his investigation.
He goes on to interview the mayor
Hirokawa about the parasites.
Afraid of being exposed, Hirokawa orders his
men to kill the reporter after the interview.
Meanwhile, Migi senses the presence of 5 parasites
nearby while returning home from school. Migi
advises Shinichi to run away. However, they are
eventually caught and to their astonishment,
they learn that they are faced with a
man that has 5 monsters in his body.
A cat and mouse chase follows. After reading the
man’s brain waves, Migi advises Shinichi to kill
the original monster using his speed. Shinichi
then swings by a tree and beheads the monster.
They then run away and the man again comes back
to life. The parasite in the man’s right hand,
who is revealed to be Goto, takes the place of the
head and orders the parasite in the severed head,
Miki, to occupy the right hand.
When Kuramori returns home,
he finds police in front of his building.
Panicking, he runs to his apartment to
learn that his daughters had been killed by the
parasites who had come looking for him. Kuramori
is traumatized by his daughter’s death and
refuses to cooperate with Detective Hirama.
Meanwhile, Tamiya is furious to learn that the
parasites tried to kill Shinichi and Kuramori.
She expresses regret over the senseless killing
of Kuramori’s daughter. She fears that senselessly
killing humans could give rise to an uprising
strong enough to exterminate all parasites.
She then threatens to kill Hirokawa and other
parasites herself if they again try to undermine
her authority. Ever since Tamiya has given birth
to her human son, she is increasingly exhibiting
more and more human instincts such as kindness
and going above and beyond to care for one’s
own child. She breast feeds the baby and tries
to make him laugh by making funny expressions.
Detective Hirama learns that Kuramori has
fled from the hotel where he was kept under
police protection and immediately heads out to
look for the bereaved father with his unit.
Swearing revenge, Kuramori kidnaps
Tamiya’s son and leaves her a note,
calling her to a park so she can see him kill her
baby. Tamiya immediately rushes to Shinichi’s home
to seek his help. However, Shinichi isn’t home
and she runs into his girlfriend Satomi. Satomi
gives Tamiya Shinichi’s number. Tamiya
explains to him on the phone that she
isn’t responsible for the parasites coming after
them and asks for his help to save her baby.
As Tamiya and Shinichi arrive at the park to meet
Kuramori, the Japanese Special Assault Team(SAT)
led by Yamagishi starts preparing to raid the town
hall to kill all the parasites after learning the
truth about Hirokawa, the city’s mayor. People
inside the building are ordered to vacate the
premises. They are made to undergo an x-ray scan
and the monsters identified by the x-ray machine
are executed on the spot. After evacuating
the civilians, the SAT team then storms into
the building and corner Hirokawa. After finding
himself cornered, Hirokawa goes on a rant against
humans calling them the real parasite. But,
Yamagishi cuts his monologue short and sprays
bullets into his body. To his astonishment,
Yamagishi realises that Hirokawa is actually
a human. Hirokawa was helping the monsters
because of his principles and beliefs. Just
as the armed men begin to wrap their heads around
the revelation, the last remaining parasite, Goto,
shows up. The SAT team bombards the monster with
bullets but he blocks them without much effort.
At the park, Tamiya explains to Kuramori that
she didn’t order the killing of his daughter but
Kuramori, blinded by revenge, refuses to believe
her. Shinichi also tries to persuade him against
harming the innocent baby. However, Kuromori
is hell bent on avenging his daughter’s death.
As he proceeds to throw Tamiya’s son
from the bridge, the police arrives.
Left with no other choice, Tamiya kills Kuramori
and saves her son, exposing herself in the
process. Kuramori falls to his death and the
police point their guns at Tamiya. Shinichi is
stunned that Tamiya exposed her identity to save
a human baby’s life. Instead of running away,
Tamiya starts walking towards Shinichi with the
baby. Detective Hirama warns her against taking
another step but she continues to walk towards
Shinichi and the police sprays her with bullets.
Clinging on to her last few breaths, she hands
the baby to Shinichi and tells him that she
doesn’t wish to run away because she doesn’t want
her son to live the life of a fugitive. She asks
Shinichi to look after her son before collapsing
and passing away. Shinichi breaks into tears
as Tamiya reminds him of his late mother. Satomi
arrives on the scene and comforts her boyfriend.
As Detective Hirama proceeds to take Shinichi
for an interrogation, he is informed that
the SAT team is dead. He immediately
rushes to the town hall with Shinichi.
At the town hall, Goto throws Yamagishi’s
severed before Hirama. Angered, Hirama shoots
the parasite but it deflects the bullets back to
him, killing him on the spot. The police retreat
while sensing danger to his life, Shinichi runs
away in a car. Goto follows him on a motor bike
and eventually catches up to him. Before Shinichi
and Migi could even realise, Goto jumps on top of
his car and attacks him. Migi drives the car as
Shinichi tries to dodge the parasite’s attack.
A long struggle follows and Migi eventually loses
control of the car and it drives off a bridge.
However, Migi manages to save Shinichi and itself.
Goto sustains injury but also survives the crash
and starts chasing the two into the forest. Migi
comes up with a plan and they decide to ambush
the parasite. Migi attacks the parasite from a
tree and Shinichi sneaks up on him from behind
but the parasite tanks their plan. Left with no
choice, Migi asks Shinichi to run away as it keeps
the parasite busy. Shinichi refuses to sacrifice
his friend but Migi forces him to go. Goto
eventually kills Migi and Shinichi runs away.
Shinichi seeks refuge in an abandoned building
and calls Satomi. He is devastated by
Migi’s death and Satomi comforts him.
She reminds him that he still has her and this
is not the end. The two then start making out.
The next morning, Shinichi discovers that a
part of Migi is still in his right hand due
to his body being infected with Migi’s
cell. In the previous part of the film,
Migi had used its cells to repair Shinichi’s heart
damaged by a parasite. Shinichi also realises that
if Migi is still a part of his body, Goto can use
that to track him. He freaks and proceeds to flee
with his girlfriend. However, the parasite
catches up to them. To save Satomi’s life,
Shinichi reveals his location and lures
Goto into a garbage disposal facility.
A battle follows. Goto badly batters the
boy but even without Migi he holds his own.
He grabs a metal rod and stabs Goto with
it but it barely does any harm to him.
Goto then proceeds to kill Shinichi but suddenly
Migi comes to life. It is revealed that Migi had
not died. It had transferred to Goto’s hand. Migi
returns to Shinichi’s right hand and Goto starts
disintegrating because of the toxins released
by Migi in his body. At last, the last monster,
Goto’s torso with a beating heart, remains.
Migi reveals that there’s a 50/50 chance of Goto
surviving. Refusing to let that happen, Shinichi
proceeds to kill the monsters but suddenly
remembers Tamiya’s words that these parasites
are just trying to survive on earth just like
humans. But Shinichi ultimately decides that
even if the parasites are just trying to survive,
he must protect the ones he loves. He tells the
monster that humans may not be perfect but they
deserve to live before throwing it in the fire.
Few days later, as Shinichi does his homework,
Migi tells him that since all monsters have been
killed, there’s no need for it to be around.
Migi says that if it stays around, it could only
cause problems for Shinichi with the authorities.
Migi intends to go into hibernation for
several years, decades or perhaps to death
and in return Shinichi will get his right
hand back. Shinichi is heartbroken to hear
his plans to leave but Migi tells him that it
is time for them to walk alone. Migi thanks
Shinichi for everything before turning into a
normal hand as Shinichi breaks into tears.
Some years pass by. Shinichi and Satomi meet to
visit Tamiya’s son, Taiki Tamiya. The baby seems
to be fond of the two and runs to them.
Afterwards, Shinichi goes to buy coffee
for Satomi. Uragami, the serial killer from
earlier in the movie, watches him leave and
uses the opportunity to kidnap Satomi, taking her
to the top of a building. Shinichi notices him and
follows him to the roof. The deranged killer holds
Satomi at knife point and states his belief that
all humans are monsters because they have been
killing each other since time immemorial. Uragami,
who thinks that Shinichi is a parasite, then asks
him for his opinion. Shinichi proceeds to reveal
his identity to the killer but Satomi discourages
him from doing so. Angered, the killer pushes her
down the building. Shinichi runs to save the girl.
He punches the killer and extends his hand from
the edge of the top. However, Satomi goes beyond
his reach. All the time he has spent with Satomi
flashes before Shinichi’s eyes. Suddenly, he
realises that he is holding Satomi’s hand and
pulls her to safety. As they breathe a sigh of
relief, Shinichi figures out that Migi momentarily
woke up to help him save Satomi.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave
a like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.